[Music]
science is all about neutrality and the
science i mean think of where science
comes from it comes from people in in
in papua new guinea it comes from people
in japan it comes from people in the
united states canada everywhere it's
it's trans cultural
it's transnational
it's trans just about anything you think
about but it's it's a way of arriving at
a consensus about
reality
and
testing that reality against observation
and if if that reality
dive that is predicted by the current
theories
then
and and and observations
say this is not quite right then science
science proceeds by error
science accepts
unlike other ways of discovering
the nature of the universe accepts that
it might be wrong
and through its acceptance that it might
be wrong it is open
to correction
steve you want to jump in yes um
science talks the talk but it doesn't
walk the walk oh come on that's the
bottom line so everything that that
peter has said is correct as a matter of
principle and is what science officially
stands for but it has not lived up to it
in its history give me an example i'm
sorry i mean
it should be perfectly obvious this is
where you know angela and i have some
disagreements on some other matters but
it seems to me
that it's pretty obvious it's that one
of the reasons why all of the so-called
post-colonial critiques have so much
purchase is because of science's own
hypocrisy with regard to applying the
method that it claims to be living up to
okay and you cannot deny it so you can't
just always be trotting out the pieties
about science tests of views blah blah
blah when you look at who's exactly
being allowed to test the views and
which views are being tested etc etc so
the institutionalization of science is
actually a very crucial issue in terms
of limiting the potential of science and
you're not addressing that at all you're
actually acting as if it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
okay so just just to clarify you're
saying the problem is not the principle
the principle
this is why i talked about francis bacon
because if you look at the way in which
francis bacon describes the scientific
method it is all about removing bias
it's about
bias that comes from many different
places so the principles are fine it's
just the way it's been institutionalized
through the university system through
learned societies i mean that's why
there's a kind of sociological blockage
with regard to science actually living
up to its full potential well of course
there may be a blockage in
my finger is still pointing towards the
sky
of course as long as the right finger
may be that bringing women and we have
to talk about women what is it with you
and women i mean
i think truth is out there regardless of
the gender and it may be that ways of
arriving at truth might depend upon the
way that we approach science
women
might have a different way of
approaching science but but
but but we're going to get there in the
end and i don't know i don't care how we
get there but it's the scientific method
that is the appeal to empirical
observation allied with
the reticulation of theories that is the
way that we're going to do it okay so
just to clarify you're saying
um there has been a problem with the way
this method has been
no not particularly i mean it might have
slowed us down but
might have slowed us down yeah but we
think where we are compared with where
we were 200 years ago i mean i think
science i think the achievements of
science the achievements of technology
that depend upon functioning but what
about the issues of domination that
she's raising what the issues of
domination that angela was alluding to
i mean i mean why should i worry about
that i mean if we're in in the pursuit
of the truth then it doesn't matter who
dominates that's where it does matter
it affects the pursuit of the truth i
mean you yourself said science has
errors and it can proceed you also said
there are obstacles to progress you're
one of them and
in
in the areas where i do research you see
this is one of the problems you know you
say it's rubbish it's nonsense etc if i
said your research in physical chemistry
is rubbish and nonsense um i'd like to
agree actually i think well
you you might but i mean the thing is
this is not a scientific argument it's a
simply expression of prejudice and so
prejudice has its role sociologically it
has its role in people's lives but it's
not a way of arriving at the truth and
oh
i very rarely had a defense of prejudice
i think prejudice comes into science
where you think
that current theories are probably
plausible but need
correction
distortion pointing in the different
direction so i think prejudice about
science being in the right direction in
general
is
is plausible
but but unlike in religion where
prejudice is effectively heresy or they
the objection here to prejudice is
heresy in science the pro the
it's it's the discovery of the
distortion of an idea that leads to
progress i have nothing against
prejudice
peter
do you know before we came on stage i
really imagined myself to be on peter's
side because i'm a humanist and i
studied engineering at university so i'm
not entirely you know outside your set
but you embody the point i was making
earlier
which is confusing prejudice for fact
you know confusing your bias for
objectivity
and this is the pro and i completely
agree with steven rupert surprisingly on
this is that there needs to be humility
in science it's kind of the basis upon
which you have to do your work because
otherwise you can't control for your
biases you can't correct your mistakes
because you'll never know that you're
making them well i think
that is entirely consistent with what i
said earlier that
that sciences is based upon the ability
to make and to acknowledge error
and i think that is the
humility you're not admitting any error
you're saying i look at the history of
science and actually i think it's been
fine it hasn't been fine there have been
huge mistakes i've made in fact look at
just eugenics just eugenics
how devastatingly wrong that was yeah uh
in indeed but i think i think the the
the core point that you have put your
finger on is that
science
should be humble
in the sense that it proceeds by
admitting no i'm saying scientists
should be humble that's what i'm saying
science is inherently humble i agree
with that let me scientist science or
scientists should be humble because they
acknowledge that they
are
making errors
and i think there's no other source of
knowledge in in in the modern world
religion particularly but art
as another example where
error cannot be acknowledged
but we we scientists acknowledge error
and that is the foundation of our
success not acknowledging error is also
the foundation of a lot of scientific
errors that's what i'm that's a point
that we're trying to make here well i
don't mind about that the fact that we
acknowledge that there are errors
in far you know it takes a long time for
people to acknowledge errors and very
often they die before it happens
there are scientists i know who have had
terrible ideas and they haven't been
proven wrong in their lifetime because
they haven't had the humility to
read the critiques of their work and see
that they might be wrong and so what
long after their death
an accumulation of research has to prove
them wrong and even then there's
resistance because they were so slow
said that
progress in science occurs funeral by
funeral
because right so this is an argument for
killing people
right i mean this is how we no no no
you're you're making the argument for
killing scientific terrorism yes
of
observation
um in science um does human observation
enable us to choose between models and
theories
um and if so how does it do that
well if you look at me you know what i'm
saying you want me to start yeah
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you